so Tristan and I really have
not connected and I just can't fake it
so here I'll take my Notebook thank you
you want to see I have my note oh you
have your notes okay okay I thought it
was for me to write down like write down
not let's see you better write down what
I was going to tell you this is what I
want you to take from this exactly I'm
big on that too especially in therapy
write down not yeah I always write down
notes always in therapy do you go to
therapy mhm I've been going the last two
years oh nice yeah it's great I'm really
not here to judge I don't have any like
anger just more like i' want like an
understanding of like how you could do
these things or how it got there like I
am curious just as to like I wonder if
Tristan ever was like I don't have
remorse no
so that's fair the next day after you
like do the deed like do you feel
anything for me personally when when I
when I cheat I feel disgusted the next
day but then so then why do you do it
again